- So I became really
good at just, you know,
either not saying anything,
and even my ballet teacher
that I was training with,
she had no idea that
we were on food stamps,
and didn't really, you know,
I wasn't eating enough.
And we were living in a motel,
and I was taking a two-hour
bus drive back and forth
from school or to get to ballet class.
I just felt it was best
if she just worried about,
you know, training me.
And then I dealt with
all of the other stuff.
And I feel like I grew up
quick, almost, in a way,
because I was exposed to so much,
and dealing, you know,
responsible for so much
at such a young age.
But there was a breaking point
when I told her that I
could no longer dance,
because it was just too
much responsibility.
My mother had five other children
that she was trying to
raise and keep in school.
This was just an
extra-curricular activity to her.
So once I told her I
could no longer dance,
she said, well can I at
least drive you home?
And it was like, no no no, you
can't drive me home. (laughs)
And she was like, I'm driving you home.
And that's when she found
out I was living in a motel.
- [Interviewer] The way
she tells this story,
she dropped you off, and
then she was driving away,
and she said she was about
halfway back to either the studio
or her home, and she just
decided to turn around and
go right back to the
motel, knocks on the door,
and what did she ask your mother?
- I don't know where I would
be if that never happened.
She turned around and she came back,
and she asked my mother
if I can live with her.
And I mean, I was like, what? (laughs)
That was not something
that I ever considered.
I knew it was normal, you
know, for a dancer to go off
to a boarding school or go off and train.
And she really broke it down
and explained it to my mom
in that way.
You know, that she had
done that at 15 years old.
And I think that it was just
a lot for her to really,
not just see the motel,
but see me sitting inside.
And there was no bedroom, and
I was sitting on the floor,
and just feeling like
this is it, you know?
Like it's either this is
what her life is going to be,
or I can change it and she
can change the ballet world.
And luckily, my mom said okay. (laughs)
And that was the beginning of everything.